in diesem moment finden grausame
angriffe auf die gesamte ukraine statt
wir erleben wie heftige waffen kiefer
eingesetzt werden wie es dort
explosionen gibt wie wir sie diesen
krieg noch nicht erlebt haben wie wir
davon ausgehen müssen dass sehr viele
zivilisten sterben gleichzeitig in kiew
wo ich in diesem moment sitze haben die
menschen angst dass sie eingekesselt
werden eine panzerkolonne ist nur wenige
kilometer vor der stadt ist auf dem weg
60 km lange panzerkolonne die hier in
diese richtung fährt ich habe gerade
eben noch einmal kurz vor dieser sendung
mit dem bürgermeister der stadt kiel
vitali klitschko telefonieren können der
gesagt hat diese panzer kommen immer
näher und wir haben große sorgen bitte
tut endlich was die welt muss noch mehr
tun sagt der bürgermeister der druck
muss noch weiter erhöht werden und am
ende sagt er wird alles was wir in
diesen momenten nicht tun dazu führen
dass mehr ukraine sterben
aber wir sehen wir dich hier und es ist
beeindruckend
du bist täglich fast 24 stunden auf den
beinen das muss man einmal sagen und
bericht ist für bild live aus der
ukraine aus kiew aus einem gebiet in dem
ein wirklich fürchterlich krieg tobt
angezettelt von einem aggressor der im
kreml sitzt und wenn man deinen
berichten auch dem was du gerade gesagt
hast auch den ganzen tag über heute
gefolgt ist gestern in den vergangenen
tagen da muss man doch verstehen dass
putin offenbar trotz aller aggressivität
trotz aller bomben nicht so voran kommt
wie er das wohl eigentlich am anfang
doch gehofft hat also es gibt widerstand
der ukraine und was ich heute besonders
beeindruckend fand ist und das hat sich
gestern schon abgezeichnet mit welcher
härte und mit welcher dominanz der
westen zurück schlägt nicht mit waffen
aber mit einer wirklichen geballten mit
eingebauten zusammenschluss mit einer
einheit und mein eindruck ist doch dass
wir so etwas wie ein in kalten
widerstand erleben des westens einen
aufstand der demokraten ein aufstand
derjenigen die für die freiheit sind und
man doch sagen kann aus meiner sicht
putin hat sich da ganz schön verzockt
das sind spannende these die auch teile
jan aber die frage die ich mir manchmal
stelle ist die kann ich auch direkt an
herrn bosbach weiter geben in der runde
was hat es damit auf sich es wirkt der
jetzt als wir die ukraine russland
zurück schlagen aber kann es auch sein
dass einfach putin ein viel größeres
ziel verfolgt und sich eigentlich nur
darauf vorbereitet noch mal richtig
zuzugreifen
putin hat ja noch nicht alle kräfte
mobilisiert die in den letzten wochen
die ukraine von drei seiten umzingelt
hatte jedenfalls bis gestern hat er nur
etwa ein drittel der verbände in
bewegung gesetzt das heißt er hat noch
erhebliche reserven und vom typ her ist
putin nicht derjenige der sagt ich habe
mich vor kalkuliert der widerstand ist
größer als erwartet ich gebe auf oder
ich ziehe mich zurück ich fürchte er
wird durch ziehen auch um seine eigene
haut zu retten wie ist deine
einschätzung vor ort erstens hoffentlich
hören können ich hoffe die schalte ist
immer noch gut wie es deine einschätzung
vor ort zu dem was herr bosbach sagt ich
teile das was wolfgang bosbachs sagt und
ich glaube wir sehen gerade in diesen
stunden die anfänge einer neuen
brutaleren grausame rinn kriegstaktik
von wladimir putin denn air china
offenbar dermaßen falsch beraten gewesen
zu beginn des krieges dass man ihm
gesagt hat ja wir werden die ukraine
komplett ein dem innerhalb weniger tage
und dann wird die russische flagge am
präsidentenpalast von kiew engen und das
ganz offensichtlich ist eine
fehlwahrnehmung gewesen denn dieser
widerstand ist hier wahnsinnig groß
sowohl in der armee als auch in der
zivilgesellschaft als ich heute hier in
kiew unterwegs war davon unzählige
männer mit mit gewehren die sie getragen
haben zivilisten die da verteilt wurden
die bereit sind hier ein heißer kampf zu
führen und wladimir putin ist offenbar
bereit jetzt waffen einzusetzen die man
aus dem syrien krieg kannte aus aleppo
kannte also diese bilder diese
explosionen die dort gerade in kreativ
einer stadt 1,5 millionen so groß wie
münchen gerade eben in diesen stunden
passiert sind die deuten darauf hin dass
ist ein brutalster einsatz wird von
wladimir putin und wolfgang bosbach hat
völlig recht wenn er sagt dass wladimir
putin gar nicht aus seiner haut kann
möglicherweise denn er muss das gewinnen
das glauben auch die ukraine er muss für
sich ein sieg markieren können und
ukrainische politiker sagen zu mir seine
größte sorge ist dass er stürzen könnte
und wenn er mit einer niederlage hier
abzieht oder einer niederlage die als
das zumindest interpretiert wird dann
drohe ihm der sturz also das schicksal
von wladimir putin so glauben einige
hängt am kriegs ausgang von der ukraine
ab und da können wir uns vorstellen was
dieser tyrann bereit ist zu tun ich
hoffe sie kann mit zehn jahren aus
russland nach deutschland wenn sie das
jetzt zu hören was empfinden sie da ich
merke auch dass das vorgehen der
russischen armee brutaler wird heiko ist
eine stadt wo ich auch war zweitgrößte
stadt der ukraine die menschen dort
sprechen russisch der bürgermeister
spricht russisch er spricht seine bürger
an völlig schockiert und sagt was hier
vorgeht ist mord das ist eine ganz
andere stimmung wie man sie vorher in
dem russisch sprechenden östlichen teil
der ukraine so nicht wahrgenommen hat
und mit dieser erhöhten brutalität
gegenüber den ukrainern hat wladimir
putin wirklich beide teile des landes
die lange zeit gespalten waren ganz
eindeutig geeint egal welche sprache man
spricht klar ist für alle nicht russland
und nicht bleibt mir putin ist der
freund sondern die ukraine ist die
gemeinsame heimat
wenn man das alles hört da muss ich auch
nochmal zu meinem postfach auch schauen
der vladimir putin hat ja schon letzten
sommer in einem aufsatz angekündigt oder
geschrieben dass er der ukraine die
unabhängigkeit ab erklärt wie konnte
denn eigentlich die ganze welt so
schlafen dass die ukraine jetzt in
dieser fürchterlichen lage ist das kann
man sich nur so erklären
also man darf das alles nicht so ernst
es wird nicht so heiß gegessen wie es
gekocht wird er wird sie auch schon
wieder abreagieren selten hat ein
staatsführer so klar und seine ziele
beschrieben wie kaputt dient und die
meisten werden gedacht haben wir setzen
auf politik wir setzen auf diplomatie
wir beschwichtigen ihn und das ist so
ähnlich wie israel er stellt das
existenzrecht des landes in frage so wie
es auch lange zeit zwischen ägypten und
israel war bis ägypten gesagt hat wir
bestreiten nicht das existenzrecht
israels israel ist immer noch von
ländern umgeben die das existenzrecht
bestreiten dass die ukraine kämpft hier
einen tapferen kampf einen
selbstverteidigungs kampf um zu
überleben aber auch für die freien
länder europas auch für die demokratie
in europa denn das muss protein
befürchten die demokratie er wusste auch
keine militärische angst vor der ukraine
haben
ja das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger
punkt und die große frage ist ja und sie
haben es gerade auch gesagt putin hat ja
eigentlich seit 2007 seit seinem
auftritt auch endlich eine
sicherheitskonferenz sehr klar
eigentlich immer deutlich gemacht was er
möchte wo er hin strebt und es ist vom
westen möglicherweise nicht immer so
gehört worden weil daran auch gedacht
das kann ja gar nicht sein einen krieg
in europa eigentlich völlig aussichtslos
bemerkenswert dass die bundesregierung
eigentlich bis zum ende die aktuelle
bundesregierung bis zum ende auch darauf
zumindest ganz klar gedrungen hat keine
waffen in so ein gebiet zu liefern auch
der meine ware müsse sanktionen wie
beispielsweise in den ausschluss aus dem
swift abkommen nicht mehr tragen also da
hat sich die aktuelle bundesregierung
wirklich alles andere als mit ruhm
bekleckert umso erstaunlicher dass
möchte ich einmal noch mal sagen finde
ich jetzt wie der westen doch mit
welcher vehemenz auf steht erstmal muss
man sagen vorerst ohne waffen aber doch
mit einem sehr sehr klaren bekenntnis
und sehr deutlich und zwar da geht das
nicht nur durch die politik das geht
zieht sich durch die wirtschaft wir
sehen sportler künstler die aufstehen
und einfach sagen nein und putins
russland muss es ja sagen es tut einem
für viele russen extrem leid das ist das
andere aber putins russland sein das
wird ja komplett isoliert ob das am ende
tragfähig ist und dazu beiträgt dass
putin sich aus der ukraine zurückzieht
ist eine andere frage ist ja auf einem
papier aber das ist eine macht die ihm
jetzt doch gegenüber steht zumindest
dass diese sanktionen angeht das hat er
so nicht erwartet aber hat der westen
putin auch verstanden haben dass am see
japan sehr gut hier direkt rheinland
dennoch eine sache ja darüber was was
mich heute bewegt hat sich vilimsky
gesehen habe wie er vom europäischen
parlament gesprochen hat da geht es
sozusagen um die beitrittsbemühungen der
ukraine da frage ich mich doch warum hat
diesem land seit 2014 niemand zugehört
das war die ganze zeit ein riesen thema
warum muss erst krieg passieren warum
müssen erst menschen sterben damit in
europa die politik umdenkt und das
bewegt mich doch wirklich weil 2014
standen die menschen auf den weitern mit
den europäischen flaggen ich war dort
mit vitali klitschko mit anderen sie
haben mit europäischen flaggen
demonstriert und sie wollten zu uns sie
wollten für die werte einstehen für die
freiheit für die demokratie und wohin
hat das geführt europa hat es mehr oder
weniger ignoriert hat auch die bitten
ignoriert dass man ihnen helfen muss
sich gegen putin zu stellen und jetzt
sind wir in einem krieg und jetzt geht
plötzlich alles jetzt ist eine eu
mitgliedschaft möglich jetzt werden
waffen geliefert ich frage mich warum
erst jetzt